what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about somebody else's show well no
we talk about us talking about us
talking about someone else's show that's
what the show is yes more or less we
comment eight yeah
welcome to us looking at our stuff we're
talking Aquaman this week joining me is
a as always the sweet den moral because
hi Dan and lon and Danielle back
together this one listen with us as well
delighted yeah let's just Aquaman guys
hey I'm feeling hi feeling yeah it's a
lot of movie it's a lot going on Aquaman
fair yeah a lot yeah I really liked it
it was uh I have ADHD so I was like yeah
anything but it's kind of where I was -
I I don't know I was just on board with
how insane it was so that like kind of
right out the gate so that by the time
that a father stopped his son mid
submarine heist and was like here's this
knife then we got two men riding sea
horses that actually made I was like
okay Dan F my thoughts in Aquaman have
been widely distributed I was right in
the middle and I listed negative which
means I hated it
yes the man did not hate document why
are you such a fuddy-duddy Dan why do
you hate water know that I do hate okay
I'm a superhero honestly there's a lot
that I like in this movie it just feels
like it's it's like eight movies there's
a lot that I like there's a lot that I
don't like there's a lot that I feel
sort of in the middle about there's just
so much it almost feels like you could
make you could reassemble this into
three complete Aquaman you could totally
make yes I feel like this movie feels
like several kids with very different
ideas of how their play day was gonna go
together to play with their DC toys too
but I brought black man so would you
bring like I brought my undersea said
what did you bring like I brought the
King's brother what you brought the
parents oh yeah I just brought these
shark toys I got from the zoo man I'm
playing my sandbox yeah this is a grim
monster like and a lot of these all
these things they are elements from DC
Aquaman comics you would just think like
you got to spread this out a little bit
you got a long take a breath
no a long view like you need them to get
multiple movies out of things you don't
want to use it all that well I
appreciate that they went into it going
I don't know what this is going to be so
let's make it everything it has
everything it's everything yeah let that
everything let's jump into it yeah
waiting I'm waiting
I have until a missed you
they've inspired you and they let out
you haha now Warner Brothers in PCR back
to just completely overwhelm you
like almost oh this is from 1z yeah is
happening pause I've or those giant mana
wars that people were inside that were
floating towards the kaiju I think so
what yeah ever even noticed them before
yeah those are those are definitely like
a constructed those aren't just animals
yeah those are [ __ ] yeah those are craft
one thing that we sort of touch on a
little bit that we we discussed behind
the scenes a lot is there's there's a
lot of like Atlanteans can swim very
fast and yet they've created also a lot
of classes of vehicle that move it about
their same speed all right well you get
tired swimming it would be like if you
could run as fast as a car but we still
had cars I think they can do it like
short distances and then they get worn
out right just got to take a car mm-hmm
just gotta take a car that's what while
we're on undersea cars one other
question that's a good sentence well we
I don't think we do get to this in the
in the trailer just a general question I
have when we see Atlantis in this movie
and they approach the entrance to
Atlantis yep there is a huge I would say
thousands of cars it's like a border
crossing there's there's TSA customers
where are all of those people coming to
Atlantis from the sea burbs this seems
like an incredible amount of commuting
happening there are no outsiders it's
turning into Atlantis yeah because there
are no Outsiders so there's like these
other seeking - there's the brine
Kingdom yeah there might be someone from
the brine King that's just visiting an
old college friend and its commencement
traffic yeah it really I mean it looks
like you know like a huge country and
another huge country and a border cross
it would be like if the the the first
shot we see of Wakanda is like if they
flew their ship but there was like all
these other hover ships lined up see
like where they come
people from Kenya we're also just like
waiting to get to traffic yeah if it
landed if Atlantis was Los Angeles then
like there's got to be an undersea
modesto there's got to be another C
Irvine well-known la suburb Edisto I
just want to know what she knows and
fruits are you not allowed to yes what
is banned yes cuz you know in some
places you can't bring apples yes
Atlantis is like these are dangerous
some archaea almost caused an
international incident on the Mexican
border because she had a hamburger
so yeah ya gotta scarf that burg down
yeah Ricky yet yeah us to Mexico or
Mexico to us us to Mexico Mexico
Borghese it was like you were gonna eat
that whole hamburger right now
yeah and she did with spite her face and
I love her let's keep going man remember
Aquaman the nerd that talks to fish I
love her side I zero zero watch as the
pure charisma of Jason Momoa
supercharges the character and
transforming it into a sexy undersea
super man who's super fast super strong
a lot of the time for dual chains but I
know where this is going cuz I've been
doing this for a long time people are
gonna say that he gets stabbed in his
knife wound okay well I disagree I
looked at it and I did I do not think he
did now but some people will say that he
did well I'm sorry I don't think it's a
knife wound I there is a scene I believe
this comes after if I'm thinking of it
correctly there's this whole kind of
like pretty woman about pretty woman
pretty in pink scene where he Black
Manta has all of the Atlantean
technology yes and he's repurposing it
and he also has some weapons my guess
this is an Atlantean weapon and that's
why it's able to
and that's what's got the Manta on it
cuz it was his granddad frogman night
and to Z because we discussed the night
week this is the things we discussed
step if you were gonna stab somebody
exactly and it's almost impossible and
even so you would hit them and then
you'd have to kind of like finesse it
guard tissue right that's perfectly used
in the same place right I mean you would
have to hit it direct cuz even if you
were like two-thirds of the variety
would still ping off the pointy third of
skin you'd have to hit it at exactly the
right angle I don't think so I think you
wouldn't they would bounce off or
something those who say that he is
stabbed in his knife wound we say we
challenge that he was and even if he was
it's still unlikely I also just take
issue with like you could okay maybe say
like well he lived if you'd lived your
whole life in Atlantis and the water
pressure everything like you maybe would
be super strong but why would it LAN
thien's have developed on Piersol skin
that doesn't make sense well he did cuz
super blood yeah he's half the plants
him yeah he's have Atlantean but he
doesn't have like super powers beyond
being Atlanta I mean I guess the
pressure you have to be able to be his
body is pressurized for his comfort
because you know when you go down into
in a submarine or any of those things
you have to do it slowly or you know I
don't know oceans but but you okay I
granted Atlanteans genetically would
have would have developed biologically
over you know natural selection millions
of years they could live underwater and
and the pressure wouldn't kill them but
there's no reason for them to have like
sword I am I'm sure there's some comics
lore that has been explained to us now
atoms and molecules when Dolph Lundgren
showed up with a Manic Panic hairdo I
was like okay and that was my answer to
like everything ready anytime I was like
wait a minute I was like Dolph
Lundgren's hair is pink it's true that I
would just kind of that is why wash over
you how much how much effects work had
to be spent on all those actors having
the hair floating
hair floating around them all the time
just the painstaking love it
yep how brutal let's keep talking Momoa
okay so his powers are kind of
inconsistent but so what everyone knows
that this Aquaman's real powers this
Mulder that hotel
a tilty ass head does something for ya
permission granted sailor I mean honey
er who stripped so as we as we do and as
a corner piece and the character of epic
voice guy he has now professed man
crushes on Gail from Hunger Games yeah
they're an admiring man crush on Captain
America yeah sure he said he would bend
over in order to give caps a pleasure
yep and now Aquaman and I'm sure there's
others did I forget about but those are
the big three yeah I mean I think that's
fair I think that's respectful yeah
absolutely I mean you can't go wrong no
it's Jason Momoa yeah this doesn't have
a man crush on Jason Ionis I stopped
caring about whether or not Jason Momoa
is a good actor he's just fun to watch
like he's Jason Momoa he's Jason Momoa
and he doesn't wear shoes and god bless
him he's good in the game of Thrones
yeah Drogo is not like every other Jason
Momoa thing like we're watching frontier
at home right now and I don't know if
it's a good show or not but god he's fun
we're like on the third season and I'm
so like I don't know if this shows fun
but like every time he's on camera he's
just throwing axes at people I'm just
like hell yeah he was in some random
Beatty show I cannot remember the name
someone will tell us in the comments
again this is something sometimes it's
just for me but he was he played you
know like the rakish boyfriend in some
be et showed he was super funny and
again it was a different Momoa still bro
E but yeah yeah they're not really doing
him any favors in these DC movies
because I just feel like they never
really want to drill down to exactly who
this Aquaman slash Arthur curry is he
was the one that I sketched out
immediately was just like oh yeah the
character is like he's Jason Momoa but
the character as written is is really
all over the map like sometimes he's
very Joey sometimes he's very smart
sometimes he's very aloof like he
doesn't care about being occupied some
things he's extremely dedicated to being
I think I mean the beer helps the there
was obviously that one scene where he's
like I don't want to hang him and you
give him
biron he's like your best bro oh no is
this just watching him slide into a Z
there beer he's drinking off camera
becomes heroic can he say a few times
like he's a drunk but he's not really a
drunk I know he and his dad like he
jumps up on the pier and he and his dad
like let's hang out and they go to a bar
and they literally drink from Dawn and
to her okay best he's a binge drinker
salty he doesn't seem drunk and then he
doesn't drink again for like the rest of
the movie yeah he does drive though just
don't even risk it the mag does the same
thing we're in the first two scenes
Jason Statham like eighteen times like
you want a beer let's grab a beer and
then never again for the rest of the
movie they just drop it tell you it's
how you get across that someone's
relatable ones yeah you have a beer with
this guy yeah he has a lot of opposing
sort of personality traits going on all
at once buddy yeah you know he's like
most bros he's very complex he's like an
onion and I think he's just you know and
the right woman can peel that onion yeah
she's gonna fix him I do love the like
he know he's like a walking Wikipedia
when he has to be there's like an
occasional scene where that he just like
da Vinci codes a scenario he's like
quantum lingual yes yes he speaks many
languages I don't know if a lot of like
when you're watching that scene I don't
know if it took two times for me to
watch it for it to sink in that he is
spotting he's recognizing relatively
obscure ancient Roman figures just by
looking at like an old worn statue of
them bro tattooed is this general I know
all about him you know what the first
thing his mom does is destroy a TV he's
clearly one of those kids works like
TV's not allowed in this house oh he
does is really just read on the
Peloponnesian War is again yeah the bro
parts just a front because he's insecure
got it mm-hmm
let's keep go grab it
Arthur curry embarks on a reluctant
quest to become King Arthur but you know
like the cool version I give you King
Arthur and he's not alone here to help
our Mira and his mother Queen Atlanta
two powerful women struggling to
overcome terrible wigs
stop all right you know this is like
you're a baby
I tell people because everyone says the
wigs aren't that bad if you can tell
it's a wig it's a bad wig I don't know
how pop stars with their and I don't
know how me with my limited budget I am
able to blend my edges movies have said
these are actually probably some of the
best shots of the wigs in the movies and
it is not just Aquaman we had the same
problem an Iron Man 2 I don't know if
it's a red head thing or what it is go
to go to cardi B's Instagram and you
will find wigs that slay for way less of
budget than what they have and probably
took away less time it's okay embrace
the bo Derek cornrows you have to wear
underneath and get those lace fronts
melted I'm done I'm sorry about that
[Laughter]
side by side
Amber Heard yes that that does not in
any way shape or form look like her hair
these are actually pretty good shots and
I wonder if they have some leave out
okay now it's a wig podcast I'm sorry
honest wig commentaries let's do it mark
it as the one true king by giving him
his comic book accurate costume holy
crap he actually makes that dumb orange
and green suit look cool hail to the
king baby hostage
I don't think so mind we telling this
story Mara
my girlfriend suffers from a little bit
of colorblindness and so when we were
watching I showed I sort of this cuts
okay you want to see the curvature yeah
sure I showed her the cut and it gets
that part Reese's he makes that RG green
suit look cool and she goes yellow and I
posit him like what she's like yellow
and green I was like what's yellow and
green she's like Aquaman suit is yellow
and green
no it's orange and green she's like no
wait no angry wait wait wait go back to
tui
what what we discovered was that through
her life and and the way that her eyes
differentiate color she has lived in a
reality her entire life where Aquaman
has a yellow and green suit that's yes
that's how she in this shot it looks a
little golden but it Dan is correct in
the comics orange my colors are in this
particular shot it looks a little gold
she but heard the way she perceived
color and particularly in this film
because it's a little bit more of a
subtle difference yeah she saw it as
yellow and we had a no that's we had
like an existential moment where we
realized that we were living in two
completely parallel and intermingled yet
separate realities one in which Aquaman
suit is yellow and green and one in
which Aquaman's is orange and green I
think you two might be having a dress
code yeah any Laurel everyone you're
showing me I'm like no it's it's gold
it's like yellow is it yellow orange or
gold let us know in the comments we want
to know where your guards down it's
orange I appreciate that because really
in every superhero movie the hero's
journey is just to get the comic book
accurate costume and I appreciate that
they literally made that the quest in
Aquaman Street Fighter ring and I love
it there at the end of like 20 plus
years of this being the hill that the
fanboys die on is they just give them
their comics get to it and we finally
gotten there yeah let's go baby did you
think there was a lot going on in
Avengers infinity war
there was so much beer because they nose
may have brought you chaos in the cosmos
but Aquaman is a whirlwind of so many
locations the movie added titles to keep
track and it's what you notice today
these aren't even all were you now for
the Sahara on route to Italy to
somewhere in the Atlantic Ocean to
somewhere think there's three somewhere
and like when I was a kid and James Bond
movies would go to like three places it
was remarkable they're gonna go to
Tangier Jones with the three places and
they you needed to keep it so straight
that they drew a map of the line to keep
track of like you know from like Germany
to the South China Sea or something not
like butter this was just like now your
Massachusetts now you need yeah now
you're in the bottom see now you've done
that's fun like that thing you do my
favorite about the locations in this
movies is that first of all it's like
there there are places like aquarium
where it's like this opening scene is
him in an aquarium and it's like
aquarium why I need you know it's the
Boston area specific yeah I I wondered
that too is like that if you just cut to
an aquarium and I'm like I get it he
said the Aquaman is a kid there yeah
yeah I kept waiting to like why is
specifically like is Matt Damon gonna
show up like why do I need to know this
is a Boston aquarium and then the the
whole movie has been like these lovers
meet and she's like I'm the queen of
Atlantis you're from Atlantis you're
from Atlantis you're from Atlantis I
never want to go back to Atlantis
Atlantis Atlantis Atlantis the first
time I see a giant shining gleaming
Camelot underwater what if that was the
Brian King job you know
you don't know well the other one I love
is the somewheres because if it's not
who did why tell me that right why do
you that is Imagi is a ship somewhere in
the ocean we mean Rhapsody when you come
in a Meritor and it's like Midwest USA
so you kind of just said Indian Ocean we
want to figured out it was somewhere in
there right right or just say like
mantas top secret island I just want
longitude and latitude lines next time
just get more and more specific like 1
somewhere in the blank ocean title is
kind of mysterious it's like dr. Evil's
lair like somewhere oh that's called 5/3
somewhere in the blank ocean is just
lazy we only need so many parts on them
we don't need too many but hidden sea
okay underneath the earth the whole
point of the thing is we're going to the
kingdom of the deserters it's like you
said we're gonna the kingdom of the
desert is we got to find our way into
the kingdom of the deserters and then
they get their Kingdom is just yeah yes
but we told me that it's like that the
character is like oh we made it we're
here here I want to do one where I want
to do an alternate cousin movie where
every time the scene changes it just is
like inside truck interior main bar
truck yeah winery yeah let's give
galaxy's all while living through
massive undersea battle speak during
nights on sea horses fighting mermaids
and crab men on efficient overly
complicated game of Thrones politics we
all are you Kings my favorites to be the
first Kingdom to join King warms
Alliance I said you had a choice boat
though my lord you need four of the
seven kingdoms to send an attack once
you've obtained the pledge to the I just
want to mention that that up do he wears
is the same up dude every girl that I
knew were for like Arjuna High dance
it's just a beautiful French for all and
I appreciate it okay how do you do that
underwater yeah
like there will be a lot of minor
nuisances to live in under water all the
time when you're just a dude you'd be
like we should just move back I mean I
don't want to go I'll take a rolling on
this like is there a bathroom is there a
designated place to play I'll get it
where it needs to go we didn't include
this create an air bubble there's a
scene where somebody mentions to Aquaman
that he smells all's got a little Bo and
he goes underwater he goes like to check
his pits which means he's inhaling
seawater to smell I thought it was
hilarious which leads to all sorts of
other also if he's inhaling seawater
just like all that fish poop and pie
ages going through his body I do want
James wanting to go full JK Rowling on
aqua explain all weird like oh and off
Leonard had an intense sexual relations
clear from yeah boy yeah let's keep
going
you've obtained the pledge to the while
still making time for Indiana Jones
adventures a little mermaid love story
up blood feud with high tech pirates and
that's before taking a quick lap in the
dinosaur field core of the earth
summoning a guide you and bring peace to
the world
wait what happen I think about go so get
ready to jump the shark all of the
sharks and then shoot at those sharks
with water powered plasma cannons
screens just tell one Aquaman story just
the Revenge of snap was very clearly
lying sound effects
that's cannon also seahorses roar they
maids but they kind of may or all the
ugly aquatic creatures are making
animals I really do I can help it yeah
it's really dumb yeah it needs to be
right in the places I needed to hit me
if this had come out in like 1984 hey I
don't know how it would have but
would have been obsessed everybody would
have been like wow this looks pretty how
do they know models and all that stuff
it's just everyone desperately trying to
say their lines underwater in a pool and
I'll be over dog to look like a
spaghetti western yes would have been
good yeah let's wrap this up top this
bonkers things and if I might make a
suggestion maybe a prequel about how
this octopus learned to play the drums
my man not quite my tempo downbeat on 18
rushing we tried to kill Oscar Gordon
yeah that was so that was my joke that
you made work because I think in this
script I just wrote like how this
octopus learns played drums and then I
just wrote whiplash clip direction and
Dan Dan and Kevin are editor like
labored through how to make that work
and you crafted it as if you were
crafting a little a little dumpling like
a bow and I appreciate it yes well it
was more about making a conversation
instead of just being like octopus
rushing or dragging it was like let's
only use a single shadow JK seven seven
let's make it seem like he's talking to
the octopus and yeah the Kevin came up
with a good rhythm and then there's a
little bit of tweaking back and forth
sand we spoke telepathically as editors
do it's much like Aquaman speaks to
finish stare at each other and get it
and get it and I appreciate this you're
able to case you've made you made it
swim instead of fly cuz its water that's
got story Jacques Cousteau Murr lady
Marie Goblin Eric fish mugger
Andrews explosive his loyalty is come on
all the new explosions really Enterprise
the waterboy Maura
oh yeah yep she can't panic
I know people think this is similar to
another comic book movie where two
ideologically opposed family members
clash over the kingship of a hidden
high-tech civilization but hear me out
this one is underwater we're not saying
it's a ripoff just to be clear we're
just saying they are very similar
they're very similar Aquaman is
underwater yeah it didn't bother me
enough to make a section out of it if
that if that's saying anything well I
will tell you it's geo preferred another
tag and I don't know if you guys - I
very heavily advocated for that tag
because I thought we had better ones
would I do that if we did not mention
the similarities between Aquaman a black
panther the only thing anyone would ever
ask about its it borrows liberally from
not just Black Panthers they're very
similar in some respects but it does do
a lot of vote like and again this is not
the same thing but on purpose the film
does omage is two other films it's like
is that pretty-in-pink seen earlier and
I am 100% certain that that was done on
purpose to be very well we mentioned in
Jones how to train your dragon - very
similar second act yes Spencer wrote us
god bless him he must have been awake at
some weird hour in the night and too
late because we have a certain pickup
window but had wrote a couple of lines
and had a great line sort of about the
playing on the Black Panther simulators
with the kingship where it's like
another movie where the hero must prove
that only someone of a certain pure
bloodline can rule why are we ready for
this guy which I loved it was just it's
too late to include it yeah see you soon
buddy we got some brilliant scenes Leto
jus
then DC went from safe Martha to
undersea blacklight poster adventures in
like two movies Aquaman
I would have owned that poster in
college oh yeah yeah it's very it's very
like it definitely has a dorm room you
just did shrooms black light you know
poster kind of vibe you bought it at
Spencer's it's very yeah it's like a
whole ooh this one in spider-verse both
were kind of like their their head trip
movies they're like hallucinogenic
journeys into superhero dome which we
need more of yeah I'm all for it
look at that Aquaman story the motion in
the ocean hmm iron manta a general
reminder that Randall Park is a national
treasure
true strength shark fresh on the boat
okay I would apologize to Robert for
making that graphic cuz we know it
wouldn't make it in however there is a
cha that used to be a hunting 101
called IKEA Heights starring Randall
Park Larry's in it and Matt Braunger
Matt Braunger is in it some friends of
mine did it and it you've probably you
might have seen it if you haven't seen
it you should go watch it because it is
hilarious it is the show that is shot
entirely in a functioning open IKEA
against their rules without their
knowledge with the shoppers milling
around in the background it's like a
soap opera and
by the end of it I think they were up to
having to drive an hour and a half out
of town because every IKEA like had
their pictures and them on the wall and
they had like been literally banned
under penalty of arrest from entering
IKEA it's an amazing man channel 101
gave us a lot of really really cool
stuff including the first time I ever
saw Randall Park was IKEA Heights and
then a weird wrestling thing where he
tried to start a backyard wrestling and
that's just the line I associated with
Randall Park is hem sighing at a bunch
of other wrestlers in a ring and just
being like guys how many times do I have
to tell you before we rest we'll take
your keys out of your pocket yeah IKEA
Heights was just gold because they'd be
doing these really dramatic scenes and
an Ikea security guard would come up and
just be like hey you guys can't be here
Randall has one of the best if you
render par he's like the nicest guy in
the world and he's a brilliant because
he will not he's the nice guy in the
world but he has no fear and they're on
their honour treasure that was one place
what happens over there on a treasure
hunt and they're like looking at a map
and the IKEA the employee walks up to
him and goes like hey I'm sorry you
can't film here and it's like no or in
the like no you can't film here and
Randall look some dead in the eyes it
just goes what about the treasure go
watch it so that was a we talk about a
one-percenter that was a one percenter
and thank you for seating this Freire
time to tell you to go see heist totally
worth it go see that ten-year-old
webseries it's so good it's great next
and Frank Langella Skeletor yeah
what is our obsession with king by
combat one fish one vote people I like
this yeah
[Music]
and to either side no okay that's a good
example of the movies just there's no
shot where stuff like that isn't
happening although it's a beautiful shot
this makes no logical sense like you
would think that anybody firing those
blasts would be like it's the king and
the second mightiest morning shoot them
down yeah take em out this is also a
really good example another the other
pitch Spencer sent it was just too late
was just that the oh Sh everything in
the ocean looks like a 90s screensaver
yeah and above you in to either side
it's romantic
oh yeah like a Winamp yeah I like it
well guys that's Aquaman that's Aquaman
any thoughts that you just need to get
out now I'm looking forward to the next
eight Aquaman honest trailers which
we'll also have to make to do with all
the material from the film yes the first
in a series of twelve I'm ready for that
octopus to get a backup band yeah I
think I think that me they need to lean
into that with each movie it just gets
bigger I went full under the sea by
Aquaman for I want a full band I want we
got our one shell trumpets inside a hot
crustacean band to form at some point
yes yeah come on guys I want to fall
under the sea Little Mermaid yeah no I
agree just full like Arcade Fire but
underwater yes absolutely what I want
I'm weirdly excited that like James Wan
looked at this finished product and was
like you know what I want to do next the
trench monsters like whatever take he's
got in his head where he's like that's
the next movie and it was like you don't
want to do a second Aquaman right away
he's like no see I got a story about
those Lovecraft things I got a tell for
me I felt like good when the trench
monsters came in I was like that's James
one that's James Wan that he loved cause
he's such a hottie CD has such a roots
in horror you could tell like that
sequence was something going on venture
yeah that's probably my favorite part of
the movie is the first time they like
dive under water off that boat yes
it'll just be like some other heroic
character ends up in the kingdom of the
trench yeah when they gotta get out you
know or like sent over there it's like
Nicole Kidman's lost days and the
trencher yeah trench warfare fine with
it I just there's something about the
fact that like he could do anything next
and he's just like nah got an idea man I
just like to say Aquaman WB property the
meg WB property has a trench the Meg the
Meg came from a trench like area yeah I
mean let's just yeah damn thing I look
both dripping Statham's character a
drinker character a drinker over their
shared love of beer
yeah that's why in both movies they were
drinking beer setting up the big awesome
finally it's a mega man not taking care
of your Caden come home that's the show
what are we doing next week
alrighty this is a big one yeah it was
an it's an undertaking yeah I think I
think we got it I think maybe it was
teased a little bit you could say 18
times
besides oh yes most honest trailers yeah
I see we'll leave you guys with that
we'll see you next week make sure you
watch the honest trailer if you haven't
cuz it needs the views see you guys next
week be nice to each other
you
[Music]